every braless twist and twerking that we
do where this part is mush
that's where we're losing power and then
our weight gets shifted back on door it
feels a lot of times because when I'm
pushing out something I'm not able to
admit to displace it and I get we found
it off so there's all these hinges
teasing and that's where Energy's coming
out so we have to learn it up hold hold
this frame in the beginning that's how I
want you to start you can hold this
right okay
so we'll try it with two hands this time
and my hips are going to be upon me a so
hon hon me angle here if I don't point
this foot at the fight and I 21 of my
body is you see how I'm laughs right and
so my hip we move with that foot you see
what's doing that okay that's my thing
so this would be extreme do you see that
so watch watch here can I call you and
I'm going to turn my front foot and
slightly turn the back foot to the 45
degree angle and my my hips are moving
with my with my feet and everything
stops you see that well some of you do
is you go extra that little bit extra
and now you caved in on the black arch
you see that okay
so we have to do that then you can see
because I'm in this position my hands
can't be even do you see that that can't
be human
right okay so what we've been doing when
do we go to katate if you guys are down
on the side and the deadness doesn't
just stay in your heart it comes into
this whole side of the body so we're
going to we're going to do it with two
hands and you have to resist this okay
and I'm just sharing and all I do is
hold those corners of my hips and my
shoulders in that relationship
and he's helping me so he doesn't he
doesn't push cuz maybe it further all
right I can't do it okay so what he does
by gradually increasing is he's allowing
me like if I feel a shoulder bite here
oh okay that wasn't it right and just
like always we're gonna in this case
you'll find the ground path on the back
foot and I just hold the structure and
by him increasing pressure it gives me
the chance to develop it so okay what
does that mean that means that maybe at
first I have this kind of raised angle
right and I'm gonna see how do how do I
get out of it how do I get out of it
maybe I don't have the bracing egg okay
maybe I feel a lot of tension so I start
trying to hold the same posture and I
start trying to relax relax relaxing
them relax until I'm able to do the same
thing but I don't I have very little if
none tension okay
so you can't have these see this in here
okay
and nor can you have this so keep your
hips
where are your shoulders so there's a
kind of tucking but not extreme is that
might have some front of my shoulders my
weights on my heels so everything is
over itself and engaged so when you have
this slight curl you're activating the
glutes when you do either one right you
actually deactivate the glutes you're
just compressing your spine here right
and this is soft same thing right i
mighta got some glute activation on this
side but not so much on this side and
again this is mushy he goes and I have
to make that pelvis angle part of what
I'm doing here so I put a lot of mental
energy in holding the pelvis not not
letting it do this hold the pelvis pull
the pelvis
[Music]
and start releasing the shoulders that
is very key that this is not tension in
the shoulders that the shoulders are
relaxed they're not doing anything
okay let's try okay so the goal is like
I said we have you gotta free that
shoulder that's it so it's a weak link
you can see them the way that the joint
operates not only do you get these kind
of 360 but the whole freaking corner
right you see that and it's on one side
of another axis of my spine then you
lose a lot of power in that okay so I
got a pretty much one well then where's
my stability where we're done with the
stability so it's not in the deltoid
flexion can't can't be it's too weak a
muscle and you're asking too much of it
so and you're trying to do this trainee
as we go to one hand right you can see
that difference it just goes dead so you
you had you have to use your own your
mind that this size nokton were over my
arm is wherever my arm is this side is
not dead so the same thing here when
he's here the feeling right I wanted out
of these biting areas and let's go to
the next one where this is death is what
I'm holding that's what I'm holding so
it doesn't matter what my arm is doing I
can still hold that I can still hold
that Here I am NOT holding you see right
here I can hold it here and I'm still
holding it do you see there's there's no
change in that pressure do you guys see
that
okay well in the same way there's no
change in this pressure I'm not really
holding that so we can go over here
and I just hold this
when I start doing that oh okay
so I pretend I'm here until I get it I
feel the pressure here and now I can
move without releasing that I take that
feeling and I do it over here
though I'm not holding I'm not holding
this I'm holding this so my arm can move
as much as I needed to because it's not
the brace name so you can do this weird
deltoid angle why don't I just hold it
here just like I'm holding this
and again the more you relax the more
you're here
[Music]
so you keep pushing I'm gonna get myself
a more worse don't just say that push
push
I give myself a worse angle you see that
and I just hold her just like I'm doing
this out of the shoulder here relax the
shoulder free this
[Music]
okay so it's it's a little contradictory
at first because you're like I'm asking
you to make these four corners right but
that was the beginner moves as you start
to go you don't want you don't want four
corners that's it couldn't be a grid
pattern so different word you you you
want a sphere you want a sphere and you
want the sphere to just change sizes
okay so all right what I doing here are
first journal got my corners aligned
right and I'm trying to not have it be
with these things you see okay and then
what I want you to do is start taking
away those things take away those things
so you can hold this and then start
relaxing relax relax relax
yes an intention to relax okay and then
I want you to see that you can hold it
because you're holding you're holding
this thing and then next drill is hey
see if you can move this some of you
start moving and you go like this okay
so I'm here I hold it and just as I can
hold it when I'm doing this right you
can hold it with your legs doing
different things okay then then why
can't this are be just a street this
arms can be distance free
and and yes even up extreme angles it's
still holding here okay so same thing
with movement when I start to move I
don't lose it I don't lose them here I'm
holding that full is this free holding
hold even when you feel it again that's
not for you to take it off hold
so when it starts to break apart on the
arm that he's holding it's when the
shoulder mechanism becomes separated and
then you try to tell yourself to relax
when you put your mind where it's biting
you
right but you might went there so
probably aren't going to let go of it so
a beginner trick is work with your
scapula so when you feel the shoulder
mechanism start to separate pull the
scapula down right imagine that this
triangle bony has right here that
there's a chain with a hook on it
and there's a ball that's pulling it
down a weighted ball when you feel it
pull it down and that's what you're
doing in this throw so when it comes
time to this throw don't lift your arm
lift the scapula home drop the scapula
keep it out of the deltoid in here hold
scapula drop the step until you don't
need that are you just working with this
[Music]
don't try tricks this technique this
version of this technique right is just
working on this thing but it's tempting
you with tip to disengage it huh you see
that so you don't disengage in it you
keep that same feeling and and you're
moving with that feeling
so in the same way that the shoulders
should be free which you're
demonstrating in here so should the legs
the legs shouldn't mean like oh yeah so
he's pushing right I'm getting
everything where I need to be I'm moving
DC by stepping same thing I had that
same feeling right I don't do this stuff
or this stuff will get me back up right
I'm doing this stuff then then I have
connection on his on his head you see
that you can think of this this part I'm
going to go past it and get a connection
on his spine line so I just moving won't
got it then I have an entering boom and
a projection
Oh
[Music]
push oh and you should be able to move
oh I'm exaggerating this deathly so you
can see right boom this is a turn
there's that crazy angle that you don't
like well you're gonna need it and then
whoa
[Music]
like imagery is very important you can't
separate your mind your idea your
intention so when I gave you that ball
like I didn't just say pull your scapula
down I gave you an image do you see now
your mind is very much a part of this so
right now you guys your imagery I can
tell this X Y so you go anywhere he's
coming in this way and then I'm supposed
to throw him back that way that's not it
you come in here in the fight turn you
see he's coming in this way I go that
way he goes into this in space over here
and I throw over there you see that so
it's more this feeling boom boom and
it's not this feeling do you guys see
that
so there's no way you're gonna get this
if you're trying to throw back at that
wall yeah and you're gonna do this kind
of stuff oh and you're also gonna bring
his head towards you you see that so
you're gonna push really hard okay so
he's he's pushing really hard and when I
go here boom you see his head goes right
to my arm my arm does not go like that
just change in the fight is what you're
really really really hard right and I
just go in and then finally you see that
so once I'm here no no no no no no no
hope he's pushing pushing pushing I do
my move it oh and I but not talking
about
so I'm just doing that in a drill
fashion get out of the shoulder maybe I
need to use that imagery of the scapula
and the way to chain and I'm doing
everything else to say there's his head
then same thing he's I'm grounded right
push that's what lets me go in boom hey
it's over we're trying to advance right
oh okay right you first learned this
technique you have a tendency of
everything goes at once so arm and let
go of it at once that's not it the
center the center moves in to see the
arms tired
the projection happens on the other foot
whoa so this you're not - no leverage
technique and you're bingeing
oh then hold their yard once I have your
angle right
[Music]